ahora podemos trabajar en la integral
triple de nuestro problema que queremos
demostrar que es justo esta de aquí así
que podemos reescribir eso de alguna
otra forma vamos a reescribir lo que o
más bien queremos hacer la integral
sobre la región r que es de tipo 1 de la
derivada parcial de r respecto de z lo
podemos reescribir así por la
diferencial de volumen entonces lo que
vamos a hacer aquí es separar esta
región r primero en la región de y luego
integrar respecto a nuestra variable z
entonces esto lo vamos a escribir como
una integral doble y luego vamos a
integrar o más bien la primera con
respecto a la que vamos a integrar va a
ser respecto de z y sabemos que se está
se mueve entre déjenme buscarlo zetas se
mueve entre f1 y f2 de xy entonces vamos
a bajar y escribir eso que aquí se está
se mueve / efe 1 de x
efe 2 de x
y lo que vamos a integrar es justamente
esto verdad la derivada de r respecto de
zeta y dijimos primero integramos
respecto de zeta y luego respecto a x y
respecto al respecto allí y respecto a x
el punto es que esa es una diferencial
de área y eso lo vamos a integrar sobre
nuestro dominio de muy bien entonces
esto va a ser igual a la integral sobre
nuestro dominio de y ahora tenemos que
buscar una anti derivada o una primitiva
de la derivada de r respecto de z que
eso simplemente va a ser r pero vamos a
tener que evaluar cuando z vale f 2 y
restarle cuando z vale f 1 entonces esto
simplemente nos queda r pero cuando la
zeta vale
efe 2x y ya esto le restamos vamos a
restarle r cuando la zeta vale f1 de x
que es lo único que nos falta bueno
poner aquí el paréntesis y multiplicar
por nuestra diferencial de aire y esto
es exactamente lo que vimos en el vídeo
anterior lo cual demuestra que si
suponemos que es una región de tipo 1
las integrales son idénticas
estas integrales que teníamos aquí estas
son las que son idénticas y tú puedes
usar exactamente los mismos argumentos y
demostrar que como es de tipo 2
estas dos integrales son iguales y que
como es de tipo 3
estas son idénticas muy bien y de esta
forma tenemos el teorema de la
divergencia demostrado y ya podemos
darlo por concluido